wo ist dein weg
emma steht um halb sieben auf danach
putz die zähne
das ist wichtig immer okay ich putze
immer meine zellen himmel oder manchmal
fast immer okay zum frühstück ist ein
normaler müsli mit milch aber manchmal
ist sie auch ein apfel und zum
mittagessen gibt es oft gemüse gemüse ja
gemüse tomaten salat
mittagessen gibt es um 12 und zwei bis
drei uhr macht immer normalerweise
hausaufgaben und von 4 bis halb fünf sie
führte ich kontrolliere das ja und du
siehst nicht wehren und nach dem spielen
räumt du auf ich möchte hier kein chaos
haben ein problem
ich weiß jetzt danke nico ich bin morgen
gegen 6 zum abendessen wieder zu hause